what we're going to be doing today is
rationing in a step away for like a
whole lost weight because there was so
many ins and outs because there's so
many ins and outs looking at graphic we
spent a long time we invested to make
sure we were really good that there's
still more to look at but unsatisfied
removal okay what I do want to remind
you of is when you have a thinking about
each of the trigonometric graph in
particular you recognize that sine and
cosine there's a strongest linked to
each other
right which is why van inside and cosine
because they really are looking at the
same reality from tributing point of
view just off by a phase shift of 90
degrees now for that reason I'm going to
go from there and somehow get a sense if
the functions are related in this very
close way then if you notice things have
particular values of the functions about
ratios like this right this is not a
graph this is a particular spot on the
graph cos theta equals whatever right if
you're doing something about a trig
ratio then you can work out stuff about
the other trig ratios in quite a
straightforward wet so let me show you
how there's some angle theorem and they
tell you okay we know it's acute now we
know that Cod of that angle provide you
this okay I could work out immediately
what what Peter actually is okay I can
put it inside a right angle triangle
because Institute and then I can just do
my normal right angle time for Trinity
shift or them attach matter and off you
go
okay now three-fifths is not one of the
exact ratios that we know about what are
the exact ratios what kind of ratio is
that you'd be like saying I can work
that out for such [ __ ]
Rohan horses this thing over here this
guy not the angle but the ratio you get
out the other end
aha it would be an example one on route
truth would be another one
Risley onto Route three or one on Route
three okay so you've got those there are
a few other we don't want to pick you
earlier but that's basically it
this is not one of them okay so how are
we going to work with this in do we
won't get something precisely the answer
is recognize that even though effort in
think is to work out the angle is that
is not work the questions asking the
question is actually asking not for the
angle but for another trig ratio so
underneath where you've written this
question taught me up by drawing a right
angle as I mentioned before because we
know fear is acute I can place the
inside a right angle triangle if they
don't work you sore reflex obviously I
can't do that but you'll see what I will
do with those kinds of questions in a
minute
okay now I destroyed it like this the
scale doesn't really matter but being I
draw one of my sides slightly longer
than the other if I were to play for
three and the five somewhere remember
it's cause for which pair of cybernetic
you are adjacent and hypotenuse it looks
to me like this size margin on this one
so just so my diagram pretty good I'm
gonna call this 3 and this 5 which makes
it up to that guy over there is that
okay yes now once you see this diagram
you're like oh okay I don't actually
need to know what feeder is to work out
these two guys because it's a right
angle triangle which means I know on the
last site is daily4 I'm not going to
laser the points about my fingers
because that is not what this question
is about three four five double-sided
triangle and now I can find out what
time figure in 10 Peter are sort of
skipping what feeder is in the first
place
okay so I can say therefore sine theta
equals color or trickery or its opposite
on the button it's just love it
and in the same way I can just real can
see up candy is going to be
these are opposite places for free not
long enough
okay so you can see here even though you
might people I should as soon as you see
this you start thinking about working on
what that angle is you don't need to
look at what the question is asking and
now a minute ago I said this works
because theater is a cute I can stick it
inside a right angle triangle so what is
speed up in an excuse now yes question
[Music]
yes what is the call I can't so for this
question because I'm not able to just
really simply tuck it inside a right
angle triangle okay and that's a bit of
early good look kçêäa is a negative
number inside one of these or your sign
product and they're all very positive
right well tensioner is negative and it
either says hey it's obtuse by the way
kind of think about why it kills you
it's obtuse salt let you sort of
cassette randomized further what is
because of that I can't just draw a
right angle triangle still will but
special one I'm going to fit the right
angle triangle in PR because we know
through the unit circle that you can
actually have an angle of a major to not
just from north to 90 if they Toki
figure is obtuse I'll add the same dr.
dot but for these purposes on try to
work out it's just were the other three
ratios if I've got can they want to
interested in our silent close event if
cedar is obtuse which quadrant Emily I
mean the second quadrant over again okay
so in this quadrant over here I'm going
to draw myself my
triangle okay I'm not over here where
all of the values are going to be
positive quadrant over here we're not
almost just sign is positive which in
right hand is met
does that make sense okay I'm going to
draw the triangle over here for a minute
which is a triangle go don't draw this
but it is up this way or is it this way
which way is special second it's this
one right now I remember when I used to
finish without your confuse number as
being this one and then I looked at it
and in silence could not work out how do
you remember which one is which
how do you remember which one you use
what do you use from the bottom I'll
tell you what I use to remember in the
end I always think back to you can do
something which i think is get quite
consistently right when you start
measuring things when you start where do
you start wearing a viewer on this
gorgeous diagram it's the positive yet
positive side of the x-axis is this guy
over here
okay now immediately is did you put that
guy on there you're like where doesn't
look right a little wonky it's meant to
be symmetrical like the unit circle is
symmetrical okay so I think quite a
lively get the first quadrant right and
I sort of use that as my template for
getting the second quadrant and third
and fourth correct I think so now you
can draw your triangle with me the scale
doesn't matter really we're just using
it as a mechanism to work out the
question but try it a scale reasonable
right there's a five and there's a 12
that's opposite and adjacent right so
which leg is going to be which one I
have a look over here which one which
one is going to be one of them is is
this side and one of those decide which
one click yeah we're also going to like
hold on
this one for 12 yeah you ready to some
of the 12 and this one's the scion or is
it getting around
I think it's the other way around
here's the way I remember 5 / 12 right
do you remember I said to you we can
define can add opposite over adjacent
but there's another better definition
it's something there was something else
it's sign of a college right now if you
remember that sign because that tells
you which is which because on the unit
circle which of the coordinates is
silent which one is cause just like
excellent wives or the Cartesian plane
the trig functions are alphabetical okay
so it's cause see are the bigger sine
theta right so that tells you which one
is opposite and which one is a data
which one is an action which ones are Y
okay what do you think of that opposite
are adjacent to the fit the supplied
information okay
yes no when they launched I'm dating
here please look so far think about it
if you're like I wasn't sure which one
it was just try it out Enki are right
firstly peter is in the corner here so
opposite or adjacent is 5 over 12 but
I'm in 2nd quadrant so therefore thank
you 5 over 12 to 10 anywhere okay
something that can help you which is
just to be a little bit careful about is
that this length of each er just go to
the left so that's why it is negative
right this is actually 5 over minus 12
and that's why you get a nexus to 10
questions or not a question
you mean why can't I risen this is five
months 12 years because my convention
just like we say we prefer just trying
to figure out anything if I gave you
this right you let all the way back when
you first met certain irrational numbers
don't lie surat fractions like that we
prefer to have that when we call it
rationalize even though there's reason
to say actually this is a bit more of a
mess but if I just require more numbers
to write this versus this what we prefer
rational to knowledge which is a little
bit easier to work with
okay in exactly the same way we just
prefer positive denominators right so in
mine 5 over 12 thousand five of myself
they have the same values so it's just
nicer to do is if for example you should
track that fraction you've got a double
negative it easier to see when you're up
on 0 okay so I'm not going to second
quadrant now can I work out what the
last sign is because that's what I'll
need to get sine theta cos theta plus
Wi-Fi going to 13 so you're gonna start
to see questions like this they will
frequently give you you know a 3 or 5 or
3 or 4 and 7 over 25 numbers that you
will frequently find in plastic or in
tribes because this is not about the key
numbers we don't make it nice for you
it's not working out what's happening
yeah
so from this we can work out what sine
and cosine of our angles are what's fine
cyber 13 you can see if you think about
it in quadrants a F G C right you can
see all your sign has to be positive so
that's why I get positive 5 over 13 but
if you constructed your diagram right
and you get the unit circle do you see
so negative is down here it's on the 12
because it goes to the left 5 13 they're
positive they're both positive way
whereas cos theta is adjacent right and
because number one is the second
quadrant cosine is negative but number
two
to the left so that's why I can negative
and slightly delicate the only reason
why I say you have to be careful is
because if what you're talking about
here is well lengths lengths can only be
positive what I'm actually talking about
is the coordinates for the unit circle
right to get let's make it